[Music]
he
welcome to the new leadership for
society series people implanted in the
information era I am Professor Brian
Lowry and I will host this series which
is 10 sessions focused on the meant
opportunity and the critical challenges
for society presented by the rapid
explosion of information in our world
we'll use the same YouTube channel for
each session and we'll send weekly
reminders for upcoming sessions today
we're joined by Mo I'm sorry Mike
rotchild author of the storms upon us
and the world's worst conspiracies and
jarth Juda a former QAM believer and
moderator of Reddit subchannel kinan
casualties thank you both for taking the
time happy to be here thank you so much
for having me great so I'd love to start
with you jitar and for you to give us
just a quick synopsis of what your
experience with Kenan
was yeah so I um I guess I kind of fell
into conspiracies after the 2016
election uh it just I guess I was pretty
much confused like everyone else was
about how Donald Trump could win given
how unlikely it seemed beforehand and
during that first year um I guess I got
kind
of I would say irritated but I guess it
just kind of bothered me that there was
things that the media would report about
Trump where they would say take him
literally when he's being figurative or
you know vice versa or even things like
when he's visiting Shinzo ab and you
know Shinzo AB drops all the koi fish
food uh fish food in the koi
pond Trump does and then they clipped
out that clip of Shinzo just focus on
Trump and make him look like an idiot so
just tiny small things like that um that
kind of just sort of spiraled out of
control into the sense where I didn't
know what who to trust in what major
media organization or figure to sort of
read anything anymore so then I kind of
found Alex Jones um specifically because
Donald Trump went on Alex Jones's show I
spent the next year falling really deep
into
conspiracies and I eventually converted
my dad into it and then by the time Q
came on the scene I was pretty much
ready and primed to jump on board and
then um yeah over the next year and a
half I was really deep into it like
spent all day looking at it just from
every angle reading as much as I could
and then ironically it was a article by
Mike Rothchild the the one of the same
the only the best Rothchild I like to
say um that actually started my I guess
Journey out um he had written a specific
article talking
about um uh it was in regards to court
cases that are being filed in the United
States essentially it was just bad data
analysis and Mike pointed that out and
that really sort of started my journey
out and then six months later I got got
out made a Reddit post moved on with the
rest of my
life um Dad was still a q andon person
then I started getting requests for
interviews um because of my Reddit post
and yeah here I am so that's a very
succinct and probably not a very good
summary but that's roughly longest short
of it I appreciate that thanks and Mike
you you were just given credit for
writing an article about kunan
conspiracy theory that helped jarth um
get out so can you tell us a little bit
about your work on conspiracy theories
sure so I've been interested in
conspiracy theories uh going all the way
back to when I was in college and I was
a fan of the artbell Coast to Coast AM
radio show and it wasn't that I believed
any of this stuff but all of it was
really interesting to me it was very
outside of my worldview and you know I
didn't know anybody who was into UFOs
and crop circles and the face on Mars it
was just it was interesting from a from
a storytelling and a belief standpoint
and I sort of bounced around a couple
different careers and then I I found
myself writing about uh conspiracy
theories from a debunking standpoint and
this was I really started doing this
maybe about 10 years ago and we really
weren't at this point yet you know a lot
you know there was the 911 truth
movement but that had really burned out
and you had the Obama birth certificate
thing but that was still very Fringe and
like that most people weren't into that
and it was you know was like really
racist and people didn't want to talk
about it which it was and so it was this
moment where conspiracy theories were
growing in popularity and there was
there were more mechanisms to kind of
distribute them and create them but it
wasn't the sort of everybody knows
somebody who believes in one of these
things point that we're in right now and
I found that there was a real market for
you know sort of a succinct journalistic
debunking of some of these things and I
and I realized that there that there
really was a need for it I've been doing
it about a year and a half in a blog I
post I'd written for the critical
thinking podcast skeptoid uh got just a
huge amount of views like 200,000 views
and I I didn't understand why so it was
this post I wrote about the uh pseudo
science called oil pulling and this is
when you swish some oil around in your
mouth like olive oil or coconut oil and
you spit it out and supposed to draw all
the toxins out of your mouth and cure
whatever disease you have well obviously
that's not a thing that's not how
science or health work but this piece
had this huge viewership and I realized
after a while that it was because Dr Oz
had mentioned oil pulling on his show
and of course he talked about it in this
like oh you got to try it it's going to
help you it's going to be great and I
realized that there were people who were
watching these figures watching these
conspiracy theorists and these
charlatans and they were looking for
more information and they went to Google
and Google could either give them things
that reinforced the nonsense that they
started to get into or gave them
information that said hey let's pull
back on this that's not how toxins work
that's not how disease works you can't
actually do that and I realized that Not
only was there a need for it you you
really could get a lot of readership if
you did it in a way that didn't talk
down to people and that understood why
people believed in these things and what
they were looking for and it it really
kind of went from there and I was able
to write my first book and I uh got a
book agent through that and published my
second book and now I'm you know
unfortunately I'm sort of busier than
ever uh writing about qanon and and
hoaxes and all of these other things and
they don't show any sign of retreating
back to The Fringe they really are the
mainstream now yeah so I'm curious about
the history because conspiracy theories
aren't new I mean long before there was
the internet there were conspiracy
theories so what is the role of
technology and the data that's
information and information that's
available to us now um in terms of
either making those things available to
people or pulling them in like how do I
think about how technology interacts
with conspiracy theories yeah it's a
great question can technology does not
turn people into conspiracy theorists
and I don't think we are more
conspiratorial as a people than we used
to be certainly not in the United States
there's been a lot of polling about
conspiracy theory beliefs and it's it's
really the percentages are the same but
what you have that's different now is
the speed with which conspiracy theories
can be created the ease which with with
which they can spread and how anybody
can now make their own and they don't
need a printing press you don't need
editing equipment you just need a a
Twitter account basically and you can
make up anything and as long as you are
really prolific and you tell a story
that some people are going to want to be
true you can not only get people
interested in it you can start making
money money off of it really really
easily so you have the ease of
communication and you have the lure of
the easy money that you can get through
you know substack subscriptions through
blog ads through all of these other
things through merchandise where now you
can be a a professional conspiracy
theorist and you don't need to write a
1500 page book you don't have to produce
you know thre hour long videos you just
post a lot of content and people will
will flock to it
what's interesting about that is as you
mentioned right you you watch in your
example you gave Dr RZ you hear about
this thing you're not sure if it's real
or not you go online and there's all
sorts of information some of it true
some of it not true I I just wonder why
is it that so many people are falling
into the conspiracy theories as opposed
to when they go find the information
being repelled by it right so and I'm
I'll give that to you jar like when you
started looking how is it do you think
that you ended up in qon as opposed to
thinking like this doesn't make any
sense and it's
unreasonable yeah that that's a great
question I it starts out with a complete
lack of trust in mainstream media I
think that is really what drove me
towards alternative media sources and it
wasn't the sense that I was willing to
believe anything that I heard it was
just that I was now suddenly open to
things that I previously would have just
dismissed like out of hand so I don't
want to like you know
really I don't want to re um what the
word you know I don't want to drag the
media over the calls because like that
happens enough to be fair and they've
always I thought they've always been
personally very fair to me and other Q
andon Believers but in the in terms of
the technology like previous question I
think there was definitely a reason why
it spread so fast and that's I think it
has to do with the just the destruction
of the mainstream media and I don't mean
destruction in terms of like
journalistic ethics and whatnot I mean
in terms of before say around
2010 it's mainstream all the newspapers
all the Articles they got their funding
via
advertisement then around 2010 90% of
their new funding and advertisement
money were going to Google and Facebook
I mean if you take an industry and cut
its Revenue by 90% what are you going to
get so they're sharing so they along
with queing on people have essentially
used the fact that website media
algorithms which are designed to engage
you and if anger is one of the most
obvious you know engaging um emotions
have sort of filled that Gap and as a
result more people have access to it
and I think essentially that's that's we
just haven't learned how to deal with
this much information this quickly being
sprouted by this many people at any one
point I guess that's that's what I would
say and Mike would you add anything to
that uh no I think that's I think that's
a great explanation I think the fact
that so many people do distrust the
media is a huge part of why these things
spread because I think it really does
stem from distrust from the feeling that
everybody is lying to you uh the media
is lying to you the doctors are lying to
you the uh the politicians are lying to
you big business is lying to you the
advertising industry is lying to you but
I'll tell you the truth I'm G to tell
you what they don't want you to know and
of course what they don't want you to
know really depends on whatever product
that person happens to be pitching so it
really does stem from if everybody's
lying to me I'm going to believe who I
want to believe and the person who tells
me things that already dovetail with
what I already believe and what I grew
up hearing and what my friends think
what my family things because nobody
wants to feel stupid nobody wants to
feel like they're being exploited or
lied to or used so you flock to somebody
who is giving you the answers who's
giving you the the real story the thing
that everybody else is hiding from you
you want to find the person who is
telling you the truth it's just that
truth at that point becomes extremely
malleable so that's raised another
question for me because it sounded like
um in Jar's story it wasn't as if he was
looking for a particular answer he was
just looking for some answer and so I
assume that's often the case how do
people decide what is the true answer I
mean what is what is truth because it
starts to sound like mainstream media is
not just you know the New York Times or
the Washington Post or ABC or whatever
it sounds it starts to sound like the
mainstream media is anyone who's telling
you the things that everyone else is
telling you so right right how do you
how do people decide what is
real true to me to me it really goes
back to what you already believe and you
know the thing I say about qanon is that
it people don't just wake up one morning
and decide that they believe in qon they
find something that reaches back to
something that they already believe so
somebody gets pulled into Q andon
because oh they already really didn't
like Hillary Clinton or they get pulled
into the antivaccine movement because oh
they don't really trust vaccines or they
really prefer Eastern medicine you find
the things that already mesh with the
things you already believe because you
don't want to rewrite your worldview on
the Fly you think you're right and
everybody else is wrong or at least
everybody else has something to hide so
you gravitate toward the movements that
make you feel like you're the one who
has the truth and it's it's not you know
mainstream it's not readership it's it's
that idea of everybody else is hiding
something or using you I'm not hiding
anything I'm not using you we are on the
same team now the fact that you're
usually not on the same team with that
person you don't think about that
because you just go with it because they
are the ones who are making you feel
good yeah I I mean I agree I think a lot
of the times a lot of the times say my
frustration with for me the mainstream
media would just be normal media just
like you know times like Channel 2 BBC
just just like major news organizations
so when during the election it's like
they wouldn't talk about say Hillary
Clinton the global uh Global Clinton
initiative right that bothered me
because I thought that was something
that should be talked about the
Wikileaks John pesters emails like
wherever they came from showing sort of
like a bit of a collusion between the
DNC and Hillary and versus Bernie that
wasn't talked about so
when the when you're not getting the
kind of information that you want that
sort of pre like that sort like Mike
said that sort of continues along with
your um previous bias you go looking
elsewhere and then someone else will
talk about it and then just like Mike
said they'll talk about something else
and you trust them and just like just
for example I remember when Alex jines
said something like oh you know they're
um you know they're tell the they're
tell the Frog's gay like that that's a
great example right or ter example
depending on how you want to put it and
he would show you like an article and it
would it's it's literally like a
misreading of a scientific paper
involving a specific chemical and I
think that a lot of the time people
really do have a hard time separating
even today literal from
figurative if someone says say Russia is
behind the nordstream attack for example
they will usually say something like
it's it's highly likely that Russia was
the suspect behind the nordstream attack
that someone else will say well well
obviously Russia blew up their own
Pipeline and then it just goes on from
there and no one's really in taking what
other people are saying in good faith um
so yeah I I just wanted to add what to
what Mike said but I might have just r
on a bit sorry yeah I'm I'm curious
about your experience in particular
because you it sounded like you were not
a trump
fan going in and you were like surprised
that he was elected but a lot of the
beliefs associated with kunan present
Trump as a um I don't I don't know if
it's going too far but as some kind of
Messiah or Fighter for
the soly right how how did that how did
that MH how did that how did you
incorporate that into your thinking so
previously it was more there was a sort
of anti-establishment
theme that Bernie Sand's campaign and
the Trump campaign had in common and you
know Trump while he was campaigning like
I'm going to be honest he was just very
funny like he made some funny jokes I I
I thought it was entertaining and then
he got into office and he was saying all
these things like you know oh we're
gonna pull out of Afghanistan you know
he's gonna bring a better Public Health
Care system like all these stuff right
he's gonna build a wall don't that I
really cared about that but like it was
only in the year previously that as I
saw what I felt like was
unfair treatment of Donald
Trump that I completely sort of became a
def not like a defender of Donald Trump
and then almost a trump supporter as a
as a reaction and and a full-blown Trump
support by the end of it to the point
where it wasn't until the end of the
year where essentially nothing happened
like they didn't do anything all they
did was pass some you know tax cuts that
any cookie cutter Republican would have
passed um I was very disillusioned with
Donald Trump and that was almost the
perfect time for Q to strike because Q
comes along and he's like no no no no no
Trump is winning everything's going
according to plan you're actually right
you don't have to socially back down
after all those stupid posts on Facebook
and ranting to your friends and parties
for the last two years no no don't worry
about it you know it's you was gonna
have the last laugh so that's kind of
how I ended up as a trump supporter like
and to be honest now it's like go d ask
I don't
know well I I want to I want to
piggyback on jarth about that that
entertaining aspect of trump I I will
never forget watching the first
Republican debate and this was uh late
2015 and it's you know there's 10 people
on stage and it's Trump and Ted Cruz and
Marco Rubio and John Kasich and all
these others and everybody sounds the
same they're all saying the same things
they all the same cut of their suit they
all talk the same way and then there's
Trump and he's telling jokes and he's
insulting them and he's just dunking on
them left and right he's getting laughs
and he's enjoying himself and I'm going
he's gonna win the nomination because
everybody else is the same except him
he's entertaining he's funny he doesn't
care about the the Norms of Washington
he doesn't care about the sort of very
practiced reaganesque political speech
he's just going to say anything and it
doesn't matter because you're enjoying
it and he's different and I'm like he's
going to get the nomination now I didn't
think he was going to win but I I
realized that what he was offering
people was character and entertainment
and turning something very dry and dull
into a into a fullbody contact sport and
I think you got some of that same
feeling with qanon and I think you get
some of that same feeling with future
conspiracy theories it's it's not about
debate it's not about you know who's got
the best tax policy it's about owning
the libs it's about about trolling it's
about having a good time and there's
something really appealing about that
for a lot of people because politics is
just dull and it's not interesting the
Trump is interesting and and it's
different and I and I really feel like
that's a big part of what Hooks people
into movements like this and you think
that's new is the focus on entertainment
new is that a part of our era or is that
always been the case I mean because I
don't you know it's it seemed before
there was more maybe this is um putting
a gloss on the past but more seriousness
than now I mean there was a lot more
seriousness it was it was Grim it was
like the the White House you know the
Oval Office is like a sacred place and
the the Optics are are incredibly
important and it was like devastating
when Jimmy Carter wore a sweater because
it meant that Americans were going to
have to turn their heat up and then
there's Trump and he just doesn't care
he doesn't care how it looks you know he
he looks dumb who cares his fans don't
think he's dumb his fans think he he's a
genius
so it is entertainment it is um you know
pro wrestling is the analogy that so
many people use and there's a lot of
that to it it's it's play to the crowd
it's like oh no you think I'm down no
I'm gonna get back up you you gotta
knock me down again and people get into
that and you can't fault people for that
Trump is just really really good at it
in a way that I can't really think of
any other politician right now who can
do
that and do you think this is a a trend
you think that I mean it's hard to
imagine that the genie gets put back in
the bottle if this is what you think
people are looking for so I'm curious
how how you imagine the future in terms
of politics given the what you just said
I I think the future is a lot more
Margery Taylor greens a lot more Matt
Gates's a lot more uh people who have a
gimmick and a brand and the way they
dress is part of that brand and the way
they tweet is part of that brand brand
and if you look at somebody like
Marjorie Taylor green you know she gets
made fun of all the time on the left
because oh she uses all these words in
correctly and her tweets are full of
typos she's not stupid she know now
she's not like educated she's not a a
genius but she knows how to get people
to talk about her and one of the things
that Trump really um I think exploited
is they hate you and they hate me they
laugh at us and we're going to get the
last laugh on them they you know Trump
would say all the time you know they're
coming after you I'm just in the way
Marjorie Taylor greenw will will will
always talk about how they make fun of
me and my typos but that means we're
winning that kind of thing I think is is
never going to leave politics now and
how what's the role with political
ideology because everyone you're talking
about now is conservative but there's no
reason a thing the conspiracy thinking
is is linked to political ideology but
how how should we Mak sense of of of the
relationship between conspiracy thinking
and political ideology if
any um jarth I mean I know that the the
sort of the anti- Bernie uh aspect
really pulled you into a lot of this and
um yeah 100% no not I don't want up but
no no no I I've rambled enough no fa um
but yeah I I would just say that I think
look I think you will see certain
conspir you won't see a complete cute on
takeover of the Republic party because
not because it can't happen but mainly
because there's no one uniform set of
qinon theories different sex different
um areas have their own like particular
beliefs and whatnot what I think you
will see and we have seen starting with
really the the you know the the big lie
was that there are specific qinon
theories that originate directly from
say aan or directly from say you know
whatever like you know
an all community board that or one of
the big influencers exactly that
permeates through a series of say you
know affiliations like the January 6
report there were people talking about Q
andon trying to talk to Trump about it
so for example the um Mike you would
know better than me but the Dominion
voting machines the
Venezuelan thing the whole fight out and
shootout in Germany so these things are
seeping into the into say the Republican
political ideology and even stuff like
the vaccine which is really I don't want
to say frightening but it is
disconcerting because Trump isn't
antivaccine
himself he like operation WP stre was
his initiative It Like You could argue
that it was like probably the best thing
did right on top but um that it's like
lot to compare to but anyway but the my
point is that he originally wanted
people to get the vaccine you know you
know it was the opposite way around with
you know Nancy py going down to San
Francisco and Chinatown whatnot but even
now when he tells people to get the
vaccine they boo him so it is all he's
kind of he's literally this is how I saw
it and this a couple of years ago and it
probably doesn't make sense but it's
like how would I explain to Donald Trump
that hey Donald there's a conspiracy
theory about you by the way something
that you heard did they originated you
now heard you think that's true so now
stuff that you say they are
regurgitating vice versa and you are now
a believer in parts of a conspiracy
theory about
yourself on top of that you're not even
the Messiah anymore because they don't
listen to everything you say so I have
no idea how to bet draw a diagram of
that let alone predict how that would
affect American politics and obviously
their conspiracy the is on the left too
right like but there not it's not like
this dude it's not like this is
different like this is really like a CO
of the
mind and Mike why don't you think
there's the the same level of conspiracy
theory right now at least on the left
yeah it's it's complicated because I
think um liberalism tends to I think Shy
Away from the sort of Messianic figures
there's a lot of like you know we say us
that kind of thing um but which of
course is a total flip from the way it
was in you know certainly the the
beginning of the Reagan Revolution where
it was like Republicans were the one who
were anti-government and like liberals
wanted the government to do everything
for them and I think that's a real uh
indication of how the ideologies have
shifted I mean Donald Trump is the guy
who's saying I alone can fix it you know
the idea of like Ronald Reagan or George
HW Bush saying only the president of the
United States can fix things
that that's just a that's a complete 180
you know I think where liberal
conspiracy theories are is maybe not so
much political but maybe more in terms
of health and this is really where
during the the the beginning of lockdown
you really saw so many wellness and uh
Health freedom and anti- big Pharma and
antix people and communi start gravit
start gravitating toward Konan because
they weren't they weren't Trump people
they they maybe were even apolitical
like they maybe didn't like Hillary
Clinton but whatever but now you start
thinking about this this virus and
you're going well who did this who's to
blame for this and it's very easy to
look at this and go was Bill Gates
because you already hate Bill Gates you
already distrust Bill Gates it was fizer
because you already distrust fiser and
you don't want anything to do with
Western medicine so it's very easy to go
down that kind of Wellness to Fascism
pipeline it's not because you're a
fascist it's just because you are
looking looking for answers and you're
looking for alternate explanations but
it's not necessarily about politics it's
about health or it's about agricultural
or it's about uh Banking and you know
some of those more traditional
conspiracy touchdowns you know
anti-Semitism was hugely popular on the
left um in the late 19th century and in
the into of the 20th century you know
many of the very early socialist
thinkers rabid anti-semites wrote you
know scabrous pamphlets demanding Jews
be deported are executed so so it's not
completely foreign it just takes a
slightly different
tack yeah I'm I'm curious about the
possibility of this um the use of um
social media to promote these kind of
theories affecting political ideology
because what you're describing to to
some extent is on the ends everyone is
susceptible and they maybe have a a
strange blending right so you have for
example
people who are anti vaccinations on the
left not anti-id necessarily but for
example anti chickenpox anti measles and
are those be why wouldn't a conspiracy
theorist like a qon go after those
people so I'm just wondering if you can
imagine um or if it's possible that the
dissemination of information the way we
have now kind of affecting um the kind
of normal political lines that we've
grown accustomed to
yeah and that's really where the big
influencers come in where it's not just
the Q drops it's the video makers it's
the podcasters you know they make these
really slick videos like planemic like
fall of the cabal these things that
they're not sort of three hours of
somebody rambling into a camera they're
like 30 minutes long and they're really
slick and they're really wellmade and it
doesn't take that long to watch and
especially if you're on lockdown and you
don't have anything else to do you're
going to go well I'm going to watch this
my friend sent it to me what ever I'll
just laugh at it but then there's one
thing in it that you go oh that's
interesting I had thought about that and
if there's one thing that grabs you in
the really anti-semitic really hateful
really conspiracy filled video well
there's probably going to be something
else and if you were already really on
the fence you're going I don't I don't
know if I need that that shot I don't
need the chickenpox vaccine I you know I
got chickenpox as a kid and I was fine
that's just that tiny little opening
that it needs to find find the next
thing and the next thing and the next
thing in your own life that that you go
well that didn't turn out the way I
wanted it to I didn't get what I wanted
there I lost something and this person
is kind of explaining things in a way
that I'm other people don't talk about
I'm not allowed to think these things
you start to feel like you're being kind
of persecuted your grievances are being
listened to and it's very very personal
every single person's journey into a
conspiracy movement into a cult into a a
scam movement that's all different
because everybody's life is different
that's why it's so hard to get people
out because everybody gets out a
different way because everybody got in a
different way and I'm curious about that
like algorithms targeting people in
particular ways because how how unique
is it I wonder um because T like you
said you started out thinking like hey
what's going on how did Trump get
elected and then you fell into this hole
but it seems that suggests that you're
being fed a steady diet of some sort did
you feel targeted like what was that
exper
like look I was I went looking for Alex
Jones like that was not something that
just sort of popped up on YouTube but
obviously once you start you know
showing an interest in a particular
thing it shows you more of that so I
think it depends on the platform really
YouTube for example it is slightly like
right leading and it's very
conspiratorial so it's not too hard to
be pushed into something conspiratorial
on YouTube and it's not even just about
like the Q andon like there was one
about something about U the nfts with
the with the ugly monkeys forgot it's
called Uh but I also know that for
example if you're talking on Twitter and
Twitter is important not because it's a
great social media tool not because it's
a great place to have discussion but
because significant people are on it
journalists are on it writers are on it
professors are on it that is significant
in of itself and when you swi the
algorithm to not just be
say time a timeline based that you just
see things that Thea over time to seeing
things that you interact with and again
things that make you
angry that is I think I just just people
are just gonna get mad they're just
gonna get mad over everything they're
just Prime to get angry they're Prime to
argue the prime to disagree and I think
this this this sort of culture just
didn't really exist on the internet pre
Facebook I mean if you refer to someone
as a Nazi and it it was it's Goodwin's
law like you people would call you fool
for just even mentioning that so I think
it's specific algorithms but also like
you said because there's so much
information in order to try and curate
the amount of information there is and
that has been given to you naturally
social media companies are going to feed
you more of what you like so with the
lack of trust in mainstream media the
lack of trust in government a
splintering sort of community filled
with millions of people who probably
haven't even met each other just around
the world I think it's um yeah I don't
think it's even a technology thing I
think it's a very human thing and the
last thing I'll say sorry I should have
mentioned this earlier the one thing I
have seen in common anecdotally about
people fall into conspiracy theories and
it's not this is not scientific so this
could I could be 100% wrong is that
there does seem to have been some sort
of preceding traumatic event that
occurred for me for example was finding
out that I had ADHD and bipolar so
specifically ADHD so that was very
traumatic because I had sort of
internalized lot of character flaws that
were obviously symptoms of um you know a
medical condition I think people also
forget coid was very traumatic when it
started like it happened very quickly
you know countries were shutting a
couple of weeks before everyone was
saying it's not a big deal then you know
the flu was the worst then two weeks L
countries are shutting borders down
businesses are closing people are on
lockdown and we had never had a VI a
vaccine for any kind of Corona virus we
didn't even know where it came from it
was so traumatic that no one had any
answers so they just sort of went
looking for answers and um yeah and I
just think that I don't really know how
to finish a sentence but that's about
it I I I'm curious about the other side
of um social media a little bit because
Tarth you you are the moderator the
Reddit channel for people who are kind
of leaving q and on I'm I'm curious
about how do people end up there and do
they and once you take a foot out are
you then also going to be like you know
ushered out quickly and easily like I
mean is it does it work the same in both
directions is it's kind of what I'm
asking it can uh for me for example I
once I was out like I was done like I
never want to hear a conspiracy about
anything for the rest of my life ever
again um for other people it takes time
there's a bit of back and forth they
need to be almost reassured that their
social standing in society will not be
completely destroyed for the rest of
their life because I I think there's a
lot of I think I just generally I don't
believe for one second that there's a
whole bunch of Q andon followers who are
as you know as who think Q is completely
correct as they did a couple of years
ago like I'm sure that they would love
to sort of go back in Reverse time and
just pretend none of this ever happened
never get into it but they can't because
they feel like if they come back they'll
get piled on and maybe some of them
should maybe some of them shouldn't not
like it's not for me that so but um yeah
I think it does depend on the person but
at the end of the day I have always
found the person really does need to get
themselves out like you can give them
the information you can sort of plant
the idea in their head just sort of
almost connect all nine dots out of 10
but you have to let them do the last
thought themselves otherwise it just
doesn't
[Music]
stick very oh go ahead please I was
going to actually give you a chance to
talk about this at a higher level so I
know that you you testified about the
threat that misinformation poses to
democracy I just want you to help us
think about you take this out of like
the particular individuals that fall
down this path and think about it at a a
at a broader social level how should we
think about how this could affect the
democ Democracy well it's it has an
enormous effect it what it does is it it
destroys people's trust in the the sort
of the basics of democracy it uh erod
the trust that your vote is going to
count that the election will be uh
certified in the way that it actually
went down you know my biggest fear going
into the midterms in 2022 was that
you're going to have these qill
Secretary of State candidates who won in
places like Arizona and Nevada um I
Wisconsin or Michigan I think and when
the when it came time to certify a
presidential election they were just
going to say no no I'm gonna I'm not
doing that I'm GNA decide who wins and
that's when you have a dictatorship when
your vote is just a piece of paper
dropped in a box and the people at the
top just decide who's going to win
that's not a democracy anymore so when I
see people already starting to downplay
the threat that there was in 2022 I'm
like no I was reading what these people
were saying these people were talking
about Joe Biden did not win I will not
certify a democrat in 2024 no matter
what and these were you know the
Secretary of State candidate in Arizona
mark finchum this was Jim Marchant in
Nevada these were people who had a
serious chance of winning and
fortunately I think enough people really
understood that yeah you know you maybe
you like Trump more than somebody else
maybe you have some questions about the
coid vaccine and you don't quite trust
it but at the end of the day you're not
quite willing to put democracy on the
funeral P maybe you are going to take a
step back and say there there are l L
that I'm not willing to cross and and my
my question going into the midterms was
are we too far gone is is this just a
forone conclusion and it wasn't and I
think it proves that the the majority of
people are not that concerned about
Hunter Biden's laptop the majority of
people are not cons that concerned about
uh cancel culture police coming for them
and you know taking away their Doctor
Seuss books people still care about
kitchen table issues the economy
unemployment you know safety things like
that and that maybe we're not quite as
far gone as something like January 6th
would have made us think and of course
we're going to get to repeat that whole
thing in the next election and it's
going to be even higher Stakes because
it's presidential election so the degree
to which misinformation conspiracy
theories hoaxes have affected people
it's happened incredibly quickly but we
we still have a chance to pull back
somewhat from the from the the precipice
of where we were I like I like the
positive spin I appreciate that the
positive I wouldn't call it spin the
positive approach yeah toar you gonna
jump in no I was just gonna say yeah I
agree I think I think Dem there is also
there's definitely a threat to democracy
because fundamentally kunon is like the
the like this kunon is literally the
Declaration of Martial law unsealing of
s dment like you know milit military
tribunals were members of the cabal like
Hillary Clinton and George Soros and
ever um followed by the public execution
right and then like all great
revolutions military fashion takeovers
everything's great afterwards right but
the thing is like it wouldn't bother me
if this was just a conspiracy theory
about like oh the moon landing is
actually a giant eyeball in the sky and
we live on the face of a giant you know
Mountain giant I wouldn't care the
problem is that like I'm sure M attested
this too is that when a prophecy fails
people tend to try and bring about that
prophecy yeah that when a group and
their behavior gets sort of more and
more agitated you know more restrictions
are placed on the group as a result they
get more agitated than more restrictions
and eventually they'll try and you know
induce a prophecy so with Heaven's Gate
it was committing suicide to try and get
the UFOs to come and take them you know
away with codon it's just a declaration
of Martial law and it's like this is not
it is not so un believable that a large
group of militia could try and know
certain cook up something to that extent
but on the other hand it's not just one
way like the Democrats funded qanon
Republican candidates specifically
because they knew they would lose and
they did but they put like about $30
million into it if I remember correctly
and Donald Trump put $18 million into
his biggest supporters so there is a
democracy is at stake but we can't just
keep playing politics with it like it's
not immediately going if you're going to
fund q and on candidates they're not
going away they're not disappearing what
you've done is you've given them more
power and sure you've won in this
election what about the next election
and like Mike says what if there is no
next
election so this I'm gonna ask a hard
question now
so I would say there's been a erosion of
trust and I think that's a part of what
you you're talking about people don't
know what to believe jar you what what
happened how did Trump win I mean
there's just people aren't sure they can
believe um sources they used to trust so
there's an erosion of trust in the
system um and the way that some tech is
used is it tries to take advantage of
that the confusion and it produces these
these explanations that draw people in I
think I'm kind of capturing the way you
all have described it to
me um and the question I have is what do
we do about that like how do we balance
the need to manage that with the also
the important principle of free speech
that people you want people to be able
to put what they believe out there and
you don't want to police whether it's
true or you agree with it like how do we
regain the trust of the of the large
population
and not in some way throttle or diminish
the amount of voices that are are also
out there so Mike I'll I'll start with
you on that well
back well I you know I think we have to
um reframe even how we talk about this I
mean people who who uh get kicked off of
Twitter for violating its terms of
service they start crying that they've
been censored and silenced well no you
haven't been silenced you've just been
told by one particular platform that you
are no longer welcome here and I I will
always think that that's okay social
media platforms and and politicians do
not decide what's true and what's false
but social media platforms do decide
what they allow and what they don't
allow and if Twitter makes a ruling that
says we are not going to
allow um you know any kind of video that
could be perceived as
antivaccine that's not say that that a
person is not allowed to watch those
things they not allowed to spread them
they just can't do it there they just
have to go somewhere else and you know
for a long time in conservatism it was
that sort of like if you you know if I
if you make a rule that I don't like I'm
gonna start my own business I'm gonna go
elsewhere I'm gonna I'm gonna vote with
my feet as they you as they used to say
and now we've kind of had it flip around
180 where it's like everybody has to
allow everything and we're going to have
free speech and and people don't even
understand what free speech is free
speech is not everyone say says
everything that they want and we debate
it until somebody changes their mind
because that always devolves into racism
into anti-Semitism into attacks on women
and people of color it it always happens
that way because those are the voices
that are not lifted up on on social
media platforms so when people are told
you can't be racist and anti-semitic
here people take it as censorship it's
not censorship it's just a platform
saying I don't allow this here the
problem is that it feeds into people's
Grievances and people already think ofs
as not being listened to that their
opinions don't matter anymore especially
if you're a you know middle-aged white
man in America you're feeling like
nobody nobody cares what I think anymore
I'm not allowed to use the terms I used
to use I'm not allowed to tell the jokes
I used to tell anymore it's why
something like make America great again
appealed to so many of these people
because great again was when I was a kid
and when I was allowed to say whatever I
wanted and when men were men and women
were in the kitchen I mean all the all
of these stereotypes that just don't
really apply anymore anymore so much of
it is is just
anti-progress and I think unfortunately
if people are opposed to progress we're
never going to get anywhere we're always
going to be living in the same
stratifications that we've lived in for
the past Generations so I think in order
to really change this you've got to
change people's minds you got to get
people open to living a different kind
of life and expressing opinions in
different and healthier ways and you're
talking about an almost DNA level
rewriting of the way millions and
millions of people were raised and
that's not going to happen as long as
you have major pundits and major
influencers who want to keep them in
that that past because it's so much more
lucrative for them I did well that's all
the time I have I really appreciate um
both of your time um both of your time
and um thanks so much for one jar
getting out there and telling your story
and and Mike um also doing the work that
you have to help us make sense of of
conspiracy theories and conspiracy
thinking thank you both thank you so
much for having me on guys mike always a
pleasure to see you soon and K I'm so
sorry for not responding
other see you later com all right thank
you both thanks bye
[Music]
bye
he
[Music]